next up did you ever have your phone
buzz only to look down and read a text
that says
can we talk
oh my god
refinery29 reports that experts say you
should never text that to anyone
if you text we need to talk it
immediately makes people think about the
absolute worst case scenarios it's a
heart attack in a text message and
should never be done rossi thoughts
don't you dare text me this okay you
just
because you know what i've done in that
18 seconds between hey
when you talk and the bubble is that
i've decided everyone died right
everyone's gone they're just dead uh
there's a bomb on the way hey you know
boom uh so every single worst case
scenario um you know they they canceled
bridgerton what no what
something terrible is coming just give
it to me straight i feel like i've
gotten a lot of them in the last few
years like they're constantly like an
onslaught of the can we talk tax what
would be a good alternative does anyone
have an idea
yes you what is your name
i i'm joe hi joe i'm drew this is wrong
[Applause]
um i take it from a science point of
view you state the problem and come up
with possible hypothesis and solutions
all right all the same text so you say
hey here's a problem this is what it is
this is what i think we should do about
it have a great day yes
i i agree i think stating the problem
right there in text that's
and and then this
possible solutions or at least a now
let's get into it
exactly what do you do for a living may
i ask
i'm a science teacher yeah that explains
it
there you go cause and effect
problem solution
thank you joe i really think you did
solve the problem and i appreciate you
endlessly thank you leave it to a
science
teacher all right
thanks joe
all right next up it's taco time in
today's food news
yes
and we have some tacos here travel and
leisure reports uh off the coast of the
u.s virgin islands of saint john there
floats a taco bar lime out is a is a
taco stand floating in the caribbean sea
you you need a speed or a kayak or a
paddleboard to get there and they serve
up fresh fish tacos vegan tacos with
paprika smoked black beans and plenty of
ice craft cocktails to keep you cool now
we couldn't get to this floating taco
bar today um unfortunately but we do
have some tacos right here drew
this is what i'm talking about
um yes i
i already started well on my phone um
and listen i would swim in the middle of
nowhere for a taco i i just think this
is neat and i i wish you remember
castaway when tom hanks was just
floating can you imagine if he just was
like oh oh tacos oh
this is so handy you're right if he had
only found a fluffy could have come in
really handy
[Music]
you